I was there about a week and a guy goes
hey you want to meet Charlie Manson you
know what Charlie Manson he goes yeah
he's here he works as a gardener in the
Catholic Chapel Garden
so he took me over to see him
and I saw him from the door I didn't go
actually go in and meet him at that
moment
and quite honestly I was disappointed
and here's this little tiny man
with beard hair he just
and I kept thinking the way everybody
talked about Charlie he would be a
larger man and he wasn't
but my first uh actual interaction with
him he was at the canteen line and he
would have rocks that he had painted he
goes you want to buy one of my rocks
for your rocks wait you don't want to
buy one of my rocks and he goes don't
you know who I am I'm Charles Manson I'm
more famous than Jesus Christ